MORNING LADIES AND GENTLEMAN
VETERANS SHOULD WELCOME. IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND
EMPLOYEES WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. THE
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE SENATE HAS MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS. TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. WE'RE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. THIS MORNING WE HAVE
CENTER MELISSA MELENDEZ WHO
WILL BE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
AND- IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
SENATOR PLEASE IDENTIFY
YOURSELF TO THE STAFF AND DO
YOU HAVE A STAFFER WITH YOU IF
SO PLEASE IDENTIFY THAT STAFFER.
THANK YOU I HAVE AMANDA FISHER
WITH ME THIS MORNING SHE'S IN
THE OTHER ROOM. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. YOU CAN THE SENATOR.
SENATOR MELENDEZ AS A REMINDER
PLEASE MUTE YOUR PHONE OR
COMPUTER THIS WILL GREATLY AID
IN ELIMINATING ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK I ASK THAT EVERY TIME
YOU WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT
YOU USE THE RAISE YOUR HAND
FEATURE IN THE PROGRAM. EACH
TIME YOU ARE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK A POP UP WINDOW WILL
APPEAR ASKING IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO ON MUTE. PLEASE SELECT ON
MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING
R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL PUT YOU
BACK ON MUTE WHEN YOU ARE DONE.
ONCE RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE
MAKE SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON
THE SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME. AND
THEN YOU ARE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO
HEARING ROOMS TO THE EXTENT
THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW. IT WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFIED TODAY. FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT. THE PARTICIPANT
TOLD NUMBER FREE TOLL NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
YOUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. IT WILL
BE DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND
I WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. ONE
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SIX FIVE FOUR
TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW
THE COULD TELECONFERENCE SYSTEM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE
SENATE. AB OR THE COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED TO
PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN. ZERO FOR SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION. PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR NOW
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU THE LINE
NUMBER. THIS CAN BE A SHORT
WAIT ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU WILL WAIT IN THE
QUEUE FOR THE MODERATOR TO CALL
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AT THAT TIME
YOU WILL BE ON MUTE IT AND YOU
WILL NOW BE READY TO ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY. HAD TO AVOID ACOUSTICS
FEEDBACK YOU MUST MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. IN PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DESTRUCTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING. AND OR MEDIAN SERVICE-
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUTED.
WHILE EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN
MADE TO STREAMLINE THE HEARING
PROCESS AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS
AS AS CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER
AS CUSTOMARY. THERE MAY BE SOME
LAG TIME FOR PARTICIPANTS WHO
ARE ADJUSTING TO THE NEW USE OF
ONLINE TO SUPPORT TECHNOLOGIES.
PLEASE READ PLEASE BE
RESPECTFUL AND PATIENT SO ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES CAN BE
HEARD. THANK YOU WE'LL CONTINUE
WITH TODAY'S AGEDA LET'S
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. I'D LIKE TO
REMIND MEMBERS TO TURN ON THEIR
MICROPHONES PLEASE. CONSULTANT
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ARCHULETA
WHAT I HEAR GROVE HERE BRO HERE
EGGMAN. MELENDEZ WINDOWS HERE
MELENDEZ HERE NEWMAN HERE CAN
YOU MEN HERE ROTH. ROTH HERE
AMBERG. YOU HAVE A QUORUM SIR
WE HAVE A QUORUM THANK YOU- WE
HAVE THREE BILLS ON THE
CALENDAR TODAY LEAVES A GERMAN
AS WELL AS COMMITTEE RULES. DO
WE HAVE A QUORUM. YES WE DO DO
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
COMMITTEE RULES. CHAU MOVED.
AND I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR
THAT MOTION THE COMMITTEE RULES
HAVE BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR-
LET'S SEE WE HAVE SENATOR
RICHARD ROTH THANK YOU SENATOR.
AND AGAIN PLEASE TURN ON YOUR
MICROPHONE SO EVERYONE CAN HEAR
YOUR VOTE CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ARCHULETA HERE.
HI ACTUALLY AYE GROVE AYE GROVE
AYE EGGMAN. MELENDEZ LENDERS
I'D MELENDEZ AYE NEWMAN HI DMN
HI ROTH ROTH AYE NUMBER. THE
RULES HAVE BEEN ADOPTED THEY
DON'T. WHO PUT HIM ON HOLD OKAY
NOW LET'S HEAR FROM OUR FIRST
AUTHOR- SENATE BILL THREE FIVE
TWO AND IS SENATOR- EGGMAN ARE
YOU READY. OKAY AND- YOU WILL
BE PRESENTING FROM THE CHAIR
THERE IF YOU WISH. OKAY N.
DOZEN ORDERED SHOES IN EGGMAN
YOU MAY GO AHEAD PRESENT YOUR
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY TODAY A
100% SB THREE FIFTY TWO
STRAIGHT FORWARD BUT WE THINK
IMPACTFUL PIECE OF LEGISLATION.
THE MILITARY COMMITTEE HAS
EXPERIENCED INCREASE IN
REPORTED INCIDENTS OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT TWENTY EIGHTEEN ANNUAL
DEPORT REPORT ON SECTIONS
SEXUAL ASSAULT THE MILITARY
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE.
DOCUMENTS SIX THOUSAND AND
FIFTY THREE REPORTS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN AND THE NUMBER ROSE
260-002-0030 SIX IN THE
CALIFORNIA MILITARY DEPARTMENT.
REPORT EIGHTEEN SEXUAL ASSAULTS
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN. THAT
NUMBER HAS CONTINUED TO JOG BUT
THE DEPARTMENT OF DEFENSE
ESTABLISH A SEXUAL ASSAULT
ACCOUNTABILITY INVESTIGATION
TASK FORCE AND THEY FOUND A
STRONG CORRELATION BETWEEN.
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT WITHIN MILITARY UNITS.
THIS BILL TRIES TO PREVENT
ASSAULT THROUGH EARLY
INTERVENTION BY MAKING SEXUAL
HARASSMENT A STANDALONE
OFFENCE. IT REQUIRES THAT
INSTANCES OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
BE REPORTED ALONG SEXUAL
ASSAULT IN THE SEXUAL ASSAULT
PREVENTION AND RESPONSE REPORT.
AND MADE PUBLIC THROUGH THE
RELEASE OF DATA. FINALLY IT
CLARIFIES A CRIMES INCLUDING%
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND SEXUAL
HARASSMENT ARE NOT PROTECTED
FROM CIVIL OR CRIMINAL
LIABILITY. PASSAGE OF THIS BILL
WOULD MAKE CALIFORNIA THE
NATIONAL LEADER IN PROTECTING
MILITARY PERSONNEL WITHIN STATE
JURISDICTION. IN WITH ME HERE
TODAY- BY WITNESS IN SUPPORT I
SHOULD SAY IS JENNIFER WHO
CERRO WHO SERVED IN ACTIVE DUTY
IN THE AIR FORCE FOR TWENTY TWO
YEARS AND IS NOW PROGRAM
DIRECTOR. AT THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD AND I BELIEVE WE
ALSO HAVE REPRESENTATIVES FROM
THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT ALSO ON THE LINE TO
PROVIDE ANY TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE. THANK YOU CENTER
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO- THOSE
WAITING AND WANTED TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. OF THE BILL. DUE TO
CONSTRAINTS REGARDING THE
LENGTH OF THE HEARING
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE
CHAIR. MAY INSTITUTE A TIME
LIMIT ON THE TESTIMONY. EACH
SIDE WILL BE PERMITTED THREE
MINUTES. ALL OTHERS WISHING TO
TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO THEIR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES. AND CHAU TODAY I
UNDERSTAND- WE HAVE JENNIFER
MASSARO WHO BE THE PRIMARY.
WITNESS ON SUPPORT AND COLONEL
DERREN BENDER AND FOR SHARJAH
REBEKAH WOULDN'T HOW'RE WITH
THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT AND- ARE ALSO ON THE
LINE FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
IF NECESSARY. THANK YOU FOR
APPEARING TODAY SO NOW WE WILL
MOVE TO ANY WITNESSES THAT ARE
HERE IN THE ROOM AND FORTY TWO
ALL THREE. HOW THE MODERATOR
ONE OF THEM RIGHT. MONTEREY- IF
THERE'S ANYONE IN I KEPT TO
HANG ON JUST A SECOND. THE
RELEASE A LINE FOR FREE. OKAY
MODERATOR YOU CAN GO AHEAD
RELEASED THE LINE. FOR ANY
TESTIMONY. RIGHT FOR ANY THANK
YOU MR IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
ANYONE IN THE QUEUE YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S. THE
FOR THE FIFTY TWO PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE DO
HAVE LINE EIGHTEEN LINE
EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ALL OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
THE CALIFORNIA. FOR THE BOOK.
FOR THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU. JENNIFER TWO
ZERO YOU'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND COMMENT. YOU KNOW WHAT I
UNDERSTAND YES THIS IS JANET
I'M SORRY THIS IS JENNIFER THE
CEREBRAL MORNING THE MORNING I
WAS THE STATE SIX ASSAULT
RESPONSE COORDINATOR FOR THE
MILITARY- DEPARTMENT FROM TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE TO TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AND I JUST WANTED TO
TAKE A MOMENT TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB THREE FIFTY TWO.
AND BY RELEASING THE CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT SEXUAL
ASSAULT REPORT TO THE PUBLIC AS
OTHER MILITARY DEPARTMENT STILL
IT ALLOWS FOR INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY ON THE NUMBER OF
CASES REPORTED BY GUARD MEMBERS
AND THE REPORT ALSO PROVIDES
INFORMATION ON THE REPORTING
PROCESSES AND PROCEDURES. AND
DESCRIBES THE WHAT THE SUPPER
PROGRAM IS DOING IN THE AREAS
OF EDUCATION AND PREVENTION
WHICH THE PUBLIC MAY NOT EVEN
BE AWARE US TO AS A TWENTY TWO
YEAR ACTIVE DUTY VETERAN I'M
ALSO VERY FULLY SUPPORTIVE OF
AMENDING THE STATE UCMJ TO MAKE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT A CRIME. AS
THIS CONDUCT NEGATIVELY AFFECTS
THE GOOD ORDER AND DISCIPLINE
OF THE MILITARY AND WE KNOW
THAT SEXUAL HARASSMENT FALLS
WITHIN A CONTINUUM OF HARM AND
THAT'S IT'S UNCHECKED IT
INCREASES THE LIKELIHOOD OF THE
SEXUAL FALL OCCURRING SO MAKING
SEXUAL HARASSMENT A CRIME
PUNISHABLE UNDER THE STATE
UCMJ. HOLDS MORE WEIGHT THAN
JUST SAYING YOU KNOW THERE'S A
ZERO TOLERANCE AND I BELIEVE
SERVICE MEMBERS WILL TAKE IT
MORE SERIOUSLY AND IT CAN
ACTUALLY PREVENT FUTURE SEXUAL
HARASSMENT INCIDENTS AS WELL AS
SEXUAL ASSAULT. AND IF IT'S
SEXUAL HARASSMENT INCIDENT IS
SUBSTANTIATED THE COMMANDER HAS
ANOTHER OPTION TO TAKE ACTION.
AGAINST THE OFFENDER THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THE YOU. THE WE
WILL MOVE ON TO YOU ANY
WITNESSES HERE IN ROOM FORTY
TWO- THREE. TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES A ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WHICH TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY TWO. I
SEE NONE. THANK YOU NOW WILL
MOVE ON TO THE WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA
TELEPHONE. MODERATOR PLEASE
PROP THE INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT ON SENATE
BILL THREE FIFTY TWO AND WE
WILL BEGIN. THANK YOU MR IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE FIFTY TWO. PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MONTEREY HOW MANY DO WE HAVE ON
THE LINE TO TESTIFY SUPPORT. AT
THIS TIME WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE. OKAY
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY- SO NOW LET'S GO
AHEAD AND- CONTINUE ON. ANY
WITNESSES- MODERATOR ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ONE MORE
TIME IN SUPPORT OF IT SENATE
BILL THREE FIFTY TWO. AND ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF SB THREE FIFTY TWO. PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME
AND WE DO HAVE SOMEONE. SENATE
MELENDEZ. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN- I JUST
HAVE A QUESTION OR THE AUTHOR I
HEARD THE STATISTICS HANG ON
ONE SECOND THE HER VOLUME
INVOICES NOT COMING ACROSS.
VERY WELL OKAY CENTER MELENDEZ
CAN YOU CLOSE TO THE MIKE WE'RE
NOT WE'RE NOT WE'RE HAVING
TROUBLE HEARING YOU. AND ABOUT
AS CLOSE AS I CAN GET CAN YOU
HEAR ME NOW. SAY AGAIN. THE
TIME IS ABOUT AS CLOSE AS I CAN
GET TO THE MICROPHONE CAN YOU
HEAR ME. LISTEN CAREFULLY. OKAY
MY QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR IS I
HEARD THE STATISTICS THAT WERE
LISTED FOR CALIFORNIA NATIONAL
GUARD FROM THE YEAR TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN. WHAT ARE
THE STATISTICS FROM THE LAST
THREE YEARS. OF THE FROM THE
LAST AT I WENT UP AS FAR AS
TWENTY EIGHTEEN I DON'T HAVE
THAT RIGHT HERE IN MY NOTES BUT
I CAN GO BACK AND FIND IT BUT
THE IT WAS CONTINUING TO RISE.
IT'S THIRTY THREE CENTER
INTERSECTION THIRTY THIRTY
THREE. OKAY PERFECT THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM THE SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES HERE AGAIN ONCE AND
IN A- IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
WHICH IN THE TESTIFIED SEE NON-
WITNESSES TWENTY FORTY WE ASK
THERE'S NONE THERE. AND- WE'VE
GOT TO THE WITNESSES ON
TESTIMONY THANK YOU SENATOR FOR
YOUR REMARKS AND QUESTIONS AND
A MODERATOR- LET'S GO ON AND
FIND IF ANYONE ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB THREE FIFTY
TWO PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AND THANK YOU
MODERATOR LINES ARE OPEN YOU
CAN CALL THEM INDIVIDUALLY- IN
OPPOSITION. MY REPROOF PROPERTY
WITNESSES ON IN OPPOSITION OF
SENATE BILL THREE FIFTY TWO ONE
MORE TIME. THANK YOU MR IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THREE FIFTY TWO PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU SO MUCH. TO GET A MOTION
MOVED THE BILL SENATOR RICHARD
ROTH. AND LET ME GO AHEAD AND
ONE MORE TIME MODERATORS I LIKE
TO THANK EVERYONE FOR THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AND-
WE'VE GOT A MOTION ON THE FLOOR-
ANY QUESTIONS SENATORS. YES
MISTER GENERATING I'M SORRY SEN
JOSH NEWMAN. SENATE READY I'D I
JUST WANT TO COMMEND YOU ON
THIS BILL- AND FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS IMPORTANT
AREA I REQUEST TO BE ADDED AS A
CO AUTHOR AS A MOVES FORWARD
THANK YOU. THANK YOU CENTER
EGGMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I WOULD JUST THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE AND LOOK
CONTENT AND HAPPY TO BE ON THIS
COMMITTEE- WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU AND THIS IS A FIRST BILL I
PRESENTED HERE. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO THIS CONTINUING AT
THIS LINE OF WORK THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR. AND WE'RE
MOTION. WE HAVE CENTER RICHARD
ROTH- GANDER- CONSULTANT PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS THE FIRST RE REFER TO
SENATE JUDICIARY ARCHULETA AYE
ARCHULETA AYE GROVE. ROVE I
WROTE HI EGGMAN EGGMAN I
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ ON SB THREE
FIFTY TWO I MELENDEZ AYE NEWMAN
ALL RIGHT NEWMAN AYE ROTH OF
ROTH HI NUMBER. THE BILL WILL
BE ON CALL. THANK YOU AND NOW
I'M GOING TO PRESENT MY BILL
SO- SENATOR SHANNON GROVE I'LL
HAVE YOU TAKE OVER. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR HAS SENATOR
ARCHULETA WILL PRESENT SB SIX
FOURTEEN. GO AHEAD SIR. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- AND MEMBERS
I'M HERE TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
SIX FOURTEEN I WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
CALIFORNIA HAS ALWAYS LED THE
WAY IN PROVIDING PROGRAM
SUPPORTING AND HELPING SERVICE
MEMBERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
HOWEVER POSSIBLE. ON TWENTY
TWELVE THE LEGISLATOR.
AUTHORIZES THE CREATION OF A
SPECIAL FUND TO BETTER
ADMINISTER MORALE WELFARE AND
RECREATION PROGRAMS CREATING
THE MILITARY DEPARTMENT SUPPORT
FUND IN THE TREASURY. HOWEVER
STATE CONTRACTING LAW CURRENTLY
PROHIBITS THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT FROM USING DONATED
FUNDS TO ADMINISTER THE MORALE
WELFARE AND RECREATION PROGRAMS.
SENATE BILL SIX FOURTEEN SIX TO
FIX THIS OVERSIGHT BY
AUTHORIZING THE MILITARY
DEPARTMENT TO ENTER INTO
MARRIAGE MEMORANDUMS OF
AGREEMENT WITH NONPROFIT
MILITARY OR VETERANS
ORGANIZATIONS. THE EMPLOYEES
WILL ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT TO
CONDUCT CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT SUPPORT FUND
ACTIVITIES FOR THE BENEFIT OF
MILITARY FAMILIES AND SOLDIERS
AND AIRMAN IN THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL GUARD. SENATE BILL SIX
FOURTEEN WOULD ALSO AUTHORIZE
THE MILITARY DEPARTMENTS TO
SPEND MONEY IN THE CALIFORNIA
MILITARY DEPARTMENT SUPPORT
FUND TO PAY ENTITIES THAT HAVE
ENTERED INTO THE M. O. U. M.
ALWAYS. THESE MONIES CAN ONLY
BE USED TO SUPPORT THESE MORALE
WELFARE AND RECREATION
ACTIVITIES IF THEY WERE DONATED
FOR THAT PURPOSE. CALIFORNIA
OWES A DEBT OF GRATITUDE TO OUR
SERVICEMEN AND WOMEN AS WELL AS
THEIR FAMILIES AND SENATE BILL
SIX FOURTEEN WHAT AID THEM IN
ADDRESSING THE NEED THAT OFTEN
COMES WITH DEPLOYMENT. MORALE
WELFARE AND RECREATION PROGRAMS
ARE JUST ONE OF THE STEPS WE
CAN TAKE TO ENSURE THAT. WE PAY
THE DEBT THAT IS SO MUCH OLD TO
OUR MILITARY PERSONNEL. SENATE
BILL SIX FOURTEEN ENSURES THAT
WE WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
THESE PROGRAMS TO FAMILIES
WITHOUT DELAY DURING THEIR TIME
OF NEED. ON THE LINE AND
SUPPORT I HAVE JOSH BAKER OF
THE CALIFORNIA ENLISTED
ASSOCIATION OF THE NATIONAL
GUARD OF THE UNITED STATES. AND
COLONEL DERYN BENDER AND FOR
SHARJAH RECORD. WHAT CAN POWER-
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MILITARY
DEPARTMENT ARE ALSO ON THE LINE
FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. MONTEREY- PLEASE- AND
COMMUTE THE HOST A LINE AND
ALLOW MISTER BAKER TO PROCEED
MISTER BAKER PLEASE. KEEP YOUR
COMMENTS TO THREE MINUTES. HI
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY- SO AS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENLISTED ASSOCIATION OF THE
NATIONAL GUARD OF THE UNITED
STATES IMPORTANT NOTICE TELLING
US. WHAT WE DO SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND WE THINK THERE ARE A
LOT OF- ARE OFFERING THE BILL.
WE ACCOUNT THIS THING THAT THIS
BILL WILL BE. BOB GOOD IN PRO.
WHERE LEGISLATION WAS PASSED TO
AUTHORIZE AND- FUNDS FOR THE
END OF YOUR- BUT- SENATE BILL
SIX FOURTEEN OH SIX- AN ISSUE
WHERE- AND PARTNER THE NOTE
DEPARTMENT FOUNDATION BOB WHERE
OUR FOR NON. MILITARY VETERAN.
EASILY AT MONEY YEAH IT WOULD
HELP COUNTY RAPIDLY FINANCIAL
RELIEF TO OUR SERVICE MEMBERS
WHO ARE IN FINANCIAL NEED.
THANK YOU SIR- CARBON- KERNER
BENDER OR FIRST SERGEANT
REBEKAH WILL OF OFTEN HARD DO
YOU HAVE COMMENTS AND IF SO-
HOST PLEASE ARE SEIZING THE
MODERATOR PLEASE AND MEET THEIR
LINES. THIS IS A CURLER AND
BENDER- I JUST WANTED TO A REAL
LIVE NOTHING. ADDITIONAL TO SAY
IN TERMS OF A TECHNICAL. IN
TERMS OF- TECHNICAL ISSUES WITH
THE BILL OTHER THAN- WANTED TO
THANK CAL ANGUS- DAY IDENTIFIED
THIS ISSUE IN. IN COORDINATION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT AS A AS A
PARTNER AND- TOOK MEASURES TO
ENSURE THAT IT WAS FIXED AND I
WILL ALSO WANT TO THANK THAT
THANK A BETTER ARCHULETA FOR.
ALTERING THE BILL. THANK YOU
SIR LATER WE RIGHT BACK TO YOU
IN JUST A SECOND- LET'S BEGIN
WITH OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE C.
NINE LET'S GO TO ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. SCENE NINE. MODERATOR WE
ARE BACK TO YOU FOR OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT- IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
MODERATOR WOULD YOU INSTRUCT.
INDIVIDUALS HOW TO PROCEED.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX FOURTEEN. YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF SB SIX FOURTEEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. OR NO COMMENTS IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU AND
MADAM MODERATOR WE WILL BE BACK
TO YOU SHORTLY- LET'S SEE IF
THERE IS ANY- INDIVIDUALS IN
OPPOSITION C. NINE HERE IN.
FORTY TWO OH THREE LET'S GO TO
TWENTY FORTY. C. NINE MODERATOR
WE ARE BACK TO YOU ALREADY IF
YOU COULD- SEE IF THERE IS
ANYONE IN QUEUE. FOR OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL IT BE PRE GREATLY
APPRECIATED. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX
FOURTEEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK. IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX FOURTEEN
YOU MAY PRESS ONE. AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO
COMMENTS IN Q. THANK YOU MADAM
MODERATOR LET'S BRING IT BACK
TO THE DíAS DOES ANY OF THEIR
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THAT THEY WOULD LIKE
TO ADDRESS AND- SB SIX FOURTEEN.
MOVE THE BILL THE BILL HAS BEEN
MOVED BY SENATOR EGGMAN- CLICK
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I
APOLOGIZE SIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
WOULD DEF- APPRECIATE THE- THE
SUPPORT FOR OUR MEN AND WOMEN
IN UNIFORM- WHO WORKS OLD
DILIGENTLY EVERY SINGLE DAY
HONORING OUR- COUNTRY AND- SO
HERE'S A CHANCE FOR US TO. PAY
BACK IN IN A WAY OF SAYING
THANK YOU BY SUPPORTING THE
FUND AND ALLOWING IT TO GO
FORWARD TO HELP SO MANY MEN
WOMEN JEWS. ARE INDEED THAT
DEPLOYMENT AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU
SIR NOW MA'AM QUIRKY CAN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MEMBERS PLEASE
REMEMBER TO TURN YOUR
MICROPHONES ON. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FIRST RE REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS ARCHULETA. I
WHICH A LOT OF HIGH GROVE AYE
GROVER AYE EGGMAN. EGGMAN HIGH
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ ON SB SIX
FOURTEEN HI MELENDEZ AYE NEWMAN
AYE NEWMAN AYE ROTH- OR BROTH
HI NUMBER. WE DON'T COME. THE
BILL M. HAS F. FIVE OR SIX
MONTHS BUT LEAVING OUT
COMMERCENTRE AMBERG AND I'M
THINKING FOR YOUR BILL SIR
THANK YOU VENTURE NOW TAKE MY
HAT BACK AND- SENATOR NEWMAN
YOU HAVE A BILL TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL SIX SIX ONE PLEASE-
GO AHEAD AND MAKE YOUR-PRESENTATION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR BEFORE I START LET ME-
THAT NOTE THE HISTORIC NATURE
OF THESE PROCEEDINGS THIS IS
ACTION THE FIRST TIME IN MEMORY
THAT ALL SEVEN MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE OR THEMSELVES
VETERANS- ALSO WORTH NOTING
THAT THIS IS THE FIRST THIS
INCLUDES THREE FEMALE VETERANS-
FROM THE ARMY NAVY AND FROM THE
AIR FORCE THAT'S THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF FEMALE VETERANS. EVER
IN THE HISTORY OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE- AND SO
WE SHOULD ALL BE PROUD TO BE
PART OF THIS COMMITTEE LET ME
BEGIN MR CHAIR AND SENATORS I'M
HERE BEFORE YOU TODAY TO
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF SB SIX
SIX ONE WHICH MAKES UPDATES AND
TECHNICAL IMPROVEMENTS TO THOSE
SECTIONS OF CALIFORNIA MILITARY
AND VETERANS CODE PERTAINING TO
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS HOME LOAN
PROGRAM BEFORE I START LET ME
KNOW THAT I HAVE ACCEPTED THE
COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS. LET ME ALSO NOTE
THAT THIS BILL HAS SUPPORT ON
BOTH SIDES PASSAGE OF SB SIX
SIX ONE WILL GRANT CALVET THE
AUTHORITY FOR THE FIRST TIME TO
REFINANCE HOME LOANS
UNDERWRITTEN BY THE CALVET HOME
LOAN PROGRAM DESPITE THE
IMPORTANT BENEFITS ASSOCIATE
WITH THE ABILITY TO REFINANCE
EXISTING LOANS CALVET IS
CURRENTLY PROHIBITED UNDER
STATUTE FROM DOING SO. CALVET
HOME LOANS ARE ADVANTAGEOUS IN
UNIQUELY SUITED TO VETERANS
BECAUSE THE LOANS OFFER
COMPETITIVE MARKET RATES WHILE
RECURRING PORT WHILE REQUIRING
REDUCED DOWN PAYMENTS AS A
RESULT OF ITS ACCUMULATED
EXPERTISE WITH THIS VERY
SPECIFIC CLIENTELE CAL THAT
TENDS TO ACQUIRE LIST REQUIRE
LESS DOCUMENTATION IN A PRIVATE
LENDER IN THIS NOT REQUIRE THAT
BORROWERS HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT OF MONEY IN THE BANK TO
UNDERWRITE UNDERWRITING HOME
LOAN TO VETERANS CALVET FRANKLY
UNDERWRITES HOME BUT HOME LOANS
TO VETERANS FROM THE PRIVATE
SECTOR MIGHT EXCLUDE OR
OVERLOOKED BY DELIBERATELY.
WORKING WITH VETERANS OKAY
ATIONS MIGHT OTHERWISE BE
REJECT AS THREE OF CAN. HOME
LOANS PRO. RICHARD MATRIX BAY
AND- UNDERWRITING PROCESSES. IN
ADDITION TO EXPAND CALVET SET
THE ORDER TO REFINANCE EXISTING
CALVET HOME LOANS AT
COMPETITIVE MARKET RATES. SB
SIX SIX ONE WOULD ALSO MAKE
OTHER MINOR FAIRLY TECHNICAL
CHANGES TO THE RELEVANT
STATUTES. SUCH AS ALLOWING
CALVET TO OFFER LOANS WITH LESS
THAN A THIRTY YEAR PAY BACK.
WHILE ADHERING TO US DEPARTMENT
OF VETERANS AFFAIRS LOAN LIMIT
AND APPRAISAL GUIDELINES. UNDER
CURRENT STATUTE CALVET MAY ONLY
MAKE HOME LOANS TO MILITARY
RESERVISTS ARE MEMBERS OF THE
NATIONAL GUARD. IF THEY ARE
STILL SERVING AND HAVE
COMPLETED AT LEAST ONE YEAR OF
A SIX YEAR COMMITMENT. COURTS
PRISONS AND RESERVISTS HAVE
SERVED OUR COUNTRY THEY SHOULD
NOT BE PENALIZED BECAUSE THEY
WERE NOT ORDERED TO ACTIVE
DUTY. ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS TO
THE BILL WILL ENABLE CALVET TO
MAKE HOMELESS TO MILITARY
SERVICE MEMBERS NATIONAL GUARD
WITH COMPLETED A SIX YEAR
SERVICE OBLIGATION. AND THEN
SEPARATED EVEN IF THEY WERE NOT
CALLED UP TO ACTIVE DUTY DURING
THE TIME IN UNIFORM. IT'S AN
IMMENSE WERE SURPRISED TO
CALVET THAT THE CALVET HOME
LOAN PROGRAM HAS ALWAYS BEEN
SELF FINANCING AND IS NEVER
DRAWN ON THE GENERAL FUND TO
PAY. A MINUTE COSTS. OR FOR
DEBT. SB SIX SIX ONE WILL ALLOW
CALVET TO MAINTAIN THIS
TRADITION WHILE ENSURING THAT
THE CALVET HOME LOAN PROGRAM.
pCOMPETITIVE HOME LOANS MARKET
TO HELP CALIFORNIA VETERANS
BETTER WEATHER CHANGES IN THE
ECONOMY AND TO STAY IN THEIR
HOMES FOR YEARS TO COME. WITH
ME VIRTUALLY TODAY TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS IS JOHN SPANGLER
DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR
LEGISLATION CALVET. AND TERESA
GUNN DEPUTY SECRETARY FOR THE
CALVET HOME LOAN PROGRAM. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
TODAY. SENATOR BEFORE WE GO ON
HERE YOUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION- AMENDMENTS WILL
NOT BE TAKEN BY THE COMMITTEE
TODAY WOULD YOU CLARIFY THAT
PROVIDE BY APOLOGIZE SO. THE
THERE WAS SOME BACK AND FORTH
TO ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS IT WAS
SUPPOSED IS APPARENTLY NOT
NECESSARY AND WILL NOT BE TAKEN
WILL RESOLVE IT AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. THANK YOU FOR CLEARING
THAT UP. NOW WILL GO AHEAD AND
CONTINUE- WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
ANYONE WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. REGARDING THE LENGTH
OF THE HEARING TECHNOLOGY
CONSIDERATION CLEANING
PROTOCOLS COMMITTEE CHAIRED.
MAY INSTITUTE THE TIME LIMITS
ON TESTIMONY EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED THREE MINUTES. ALL
OTHER WISHING TO TESTIFY MUST
LIMIT THEIR COMMENTS TO THEIR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE MEASURE. TODAY CENTER
NEWMAN HAS JOHN SPANGLER. WITH
CALVET FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
YOU SHOULD YOU HAVE ANY. SO
LET'S BEGIN WITH THE WITNESSES-
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- THREE.
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT I SEE
NONE ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WHICH
TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL SIX SIX ONE. I SEE NONE
THANK YOU WE WILL MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA TELEPHONE. MODERATOR PLEASE
PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL SIX SIX ONE AND WE WILL
BEGIN. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB SIX SIX ONE. PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. BOB REITER
HOW MANY DO WE HAVE ED TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. AT THIS
TIME IS THERE WE HAVE NO ONE IN
Q. THANK YOU. PLEASE OPEN THE
LINES HAVE DONE BANGOURA THE
LINE. WHICH DID I HEAR NO JUST
REQUIRE AS MUCH WE HAVE SPANK
ONLINE OKAY- DRAW SPANGLER- IF
YOU WISH TO GO AHEAD. DID YOU
SHOULD NOTE NO COM I JUST.
WANTED TO REACH CENTER. GRADUAL
SINCE TWO AND THE COMMITTEE.
FOR THE- I STARK NATURE WHICH
MAKE UP. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARE MODERATOR PLEASE ONE MORE
ASK IF THERE'S A- WISHING TO
TESTIFY AND SHOULD OF SO SIX
ONE. AND LATER AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU TO COME AND TO OF S. SIX
SIX ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU HAVING HEARD FROM ALL HAVE
KNOWN AND THEN Q. THANK YOU
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS AND WITNESSES HERE
IN ROOM FOUR OH THREE- ANYONE
WISHING TO- TESTIFIED IN
OPPOSITION. I SEE NONE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. I SEE NONE THANK
YOU WE WILL MOVE ON TO
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY.
IN OPPOSITION- VIA TELEPHONE
MODERATOR PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION AND SENATE BILL
SIX SIX ONE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX SIX ONE
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. OKAY MODERATOR
HOW MANY DO WE HAVE AN
OPPOSITION ON THE LINE. WE HAVE
NO ONE IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU PLEASE CONTINUE WITH
THE OPEN LINES FOR
INDIVIDUALIZED ED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE'S NO ONE ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
SENATE BILL SIX SIX ONE ONE
MORE TIME. THANK YOU. IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF SB SIX SIX ONE YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE HAVE NO ONE IN Q. THANK YOU
MODERATOR. THANK YOU AGAIN
LADIES AND JOHN FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION AS
WITNESSES WE WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO THE MEMBERS
MEMBERS DO YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR RICHARD ROTH.
AND SENATOR NEWMAN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. A YES THANK YOU
MISTRESS I'M GLAD TO BE ABLE TO
ASSIST CALVIN MODERNIZE IN THIS
PROGRAM WHICH- HELPS
CALIFORNIA'S MILITARY PERSONAL
AND FETCH. WHICH IS ACTUALLY
CELEBRATING ITS ONE HUNDREDTH
YEAR THIS YEAR THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASTRONOMICAL
TODAY. THANKS TO THE MOTION HAS
BEEN MOVED CONSULTANT- PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS BUT FIRST RE REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS ARCHULETA BY
ARCHULETA. GROVE HIGH EGGMAN. A
AYE AYE MULLIN. MULLIN AND SB
SIX SIX ONE I MELENDEZ HI
NEWMAN ALL RIGHT HUMAN HI ROTH.
ROTH HI. THANK SENATOR FOR YOUR
VOTE THE IS ON CALL- IT WOULD
NOT A NOW LIKE A GOOD. THANK
YOU THE STAFF AND- EVERYONE WHO
PUT THE HEARING TO GET TODAY.
AND EVERYONE SHOULD OTHER BOATS
WHEN WE'RE OTHER. N. I WOULD
LIKE TO ABLE TO SEE THANK YOU
TO- THE COMMITTEE MEMBER
BECAUSE AS WAS HARBORED BY
SENATOR JOHN NEWMAN THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME THEY WERE ALL HERE
TOGETHER IT'S VETERANS-
CONGRATULATIONS- WE'VE MADE
HISTORY. AND AND LEHZEN JONES
F. YOU'D LIKE TO SUBMIT ANY
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE COMMITTEE ON
MILITARY VETERANS AFFAIRS-
PLEASE GO TO OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMITMENT AND- YOUR COMMENTS
AND SUGGESTIONS. WILL BE
GREATLY APPRECIATED PLEASE
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORD. THANK
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
IN PATIENTS WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA. AND WE WILL WAIT
FIRST SENATOR NUMBER TO COME IN
AND FINISH UP BUT THE SENT SENT
THE COMMITTEE MEETING. IS. HI
EVERYBODY YEAH KNOW WE HAVE TO
KEEP IT ON ALL SPECULATED JONES.
REMEMBER WHAT MAKES- THE PAST
ARE GOING TO OPEN UP SAME PER
DAY. WHAT IS YOUR WRITER WILL
CONNECT OKAY ALL RIGHT THANKS.
AERIAL ALL RIGHT. OPEN THE ROLE.
FOR AND EVERYTHING BE ABLE TO
ALL RIGHT THE GENERAL WILL ON
THE MEETING OF MILLET VETERANS
AFFAIRS TODAY MY SEVENTH N. WE
WILL BEGIN WITH THE RULES AND
NOW THAT WE HAVE A CORE. AND
WE'RE LIFTING THE CALL. RIGHT
AND WE HAD A MOTION ON THE FOR-
SAN NUMBER I DO ACT I. THANK
YOU ANOTHER. THE CENTER I'M
BURGER HI. CAN THE- WITH THAT
COULD CALL THE ROLL. WALDRON
OFTEN GOOD IT IS. YOU HAVE TO
SAY YOU HAVE TO THINK. YEAH
THEY THEY- THE WORLD- THANK.
TWO SIX ZERO AND COMMITTEE ROOM
HAVE BEEN A. HE. FIND IT HERE.
SB. THREE FIVE TWO SIX THREE
THREE FIVE TWO. THANKS BILL BE
AT THREE FIVE TWO CENTER ON
BIRDS. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST RE REFER TO SENATE
JUDICIARY IT'S CURRENTLY SIX
ZERO. SENATOR UMBERG BY SENATOR
UMBERG BY PHILADELPHIA SEPT AND
IT IS NOW SIX ZERO SEVEN SEVEN
ZERO. AND THEN IT WILL BE ONE
CORRECT THANK YOU. IN THE
DIFFERENT I'VE BEEN TO- ONE IS
ITEM VITAL TO SHOULD FOURTEEN
THE MOST NUMBER. BUT MOTION IS
TO PASS BUT FOR REVIEW TO A PER.
IT'S CURRENTLY SIX SIR. SENATE
UMBERG BURKE NUMBER BY. IN ITS
SEVEN ZERO. IN CANADA SEVEN THE
LOS OF FILE COMES ZERO IT MOVES
ON. NOW WE MOVE TO FILE A
NUMBER THREE SENATE SIX SIX.
THE MOST AS SB SIX ONE THE
MOTION AS DEEP BY FIRST
REFERRED TO APPROPRIATE. KERN
COUNTY SIX ZERO SENATOR UMBERG
NUMBER GUY AND I'M THE GUY.
IT'S SEVEN ZERO SHOULD IMPACT
THE MOTION BASS AND MOVES ON
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR KEEPING
THE ROLE OF YOUR. WE'VE
COMPLETED THE AGENDA AND
MEETING IS COMPLETED. IT IS.